مارغو
اذهب
اذهب لا ذعر لا ذعر
حسنًا ، هذا طبيعي
بين القوات الأكثر تقدمًا في
الهجوم المضاد الأخير لأوكرانيا ، هذا
أمر طبيعي حقًا
عندما تكون أزمة المدفعية القادمة
هي خسائر الرجال الشديدة في
وحدة الاستطلاع هذه التي تضم ثلاثة
أجانب أمر لا مفر منه ماركيز
البريطاني  أصيب بجروح طفيفة في اليوم الأول
من الهجوم
في اليوم الثاني ، وأصيب بجروح أكثر خطورة
في ساقه من المدفعية إلى جانب
مايكل ظفر ، جندي سابق في مشاة البحرية الأمريكية من
كانساس ، أصيب في يده
وبطنه ورأسه وانضموا إلى الجيش الأوكراني
معًا لكنهم التقوا بقتال داعش في  Syria
Zafar هو الاسم الرمزي الكردي السابق لمشاة البحرية الأمريكية ،
أنا بخير كقوات Recon
، لقد كانوا طرف هجمات أوكرانيا
على جبهتها الجنوبية في
القتال لاستعادة ابنها ، ثم
أتذكر فقط النظر إلى يساري حتى
ذلك الحين  البوب ​​ولم أستطع رؤية أي
شيء ، بدا كل شيء كما هو
قبل أن تصل إلى
الحفرة ، ستكون معركة طاحنة بطيئة ،
كما يقولون ، مهما كانت مزاعم
الحكومة الأوكرانية ، فإن
هذا الهجوم المضاد يتم
وصفه كنوع من العملية السريعة ، هل
تعتقد أن هذا ليس بالتأكيد لن يكون
ذلك  لن يكون سريعًا ، أعني أن مقياس
السقوط البطيء الصعب
من قبلي يتم وضعه حسب الموقع
لأننا لا نملك الموارد اللازمة للقيام
بأسلحة Blitz Creed الأمريكية الهائلة ، وقد أثبتت الأسلحة الأمريكية وغيرها من معدات الناتو
أنها مفيدة ولكنها ليست حاسمة حيث
استولت أوكرانيا على حفنة من
القرى منذ بدء الهجوم المضاد
هنا ، تلوح القوات الروسية
بعلم الاستسلام الأبيض بعد
الضربات المدفعية الدقيقة التي قامت بها
مدافع الهاوتزر التي زودتها الولايات المتحدة بمراقبتها بواسطة
وحدة ريكون Zapper بطائرة بدون طيار
حفزت روسيا قواتها بادعاءات
كاذبة بأنهم يحررون أوكرانيا من
النازيين.
أشعر بالأسف على الاندفاع ،
لا لا على الإطلاق ، ليس الأمر كما لو أن
أوكرانيا قد غزت روسيا ، بل إنهم
صنعوا أوكرانيا ، إنهم هنا يقتلون
المدنيين ويقتلون جنودنا  rs ليس لدي
أي تعاطف معهم على الإطلاق
، حيث فرضت أوكرانيا تعتيمًا إخباريًا على
الهجوم الجنوبي وتحتفظ
بسرية عدد الضحايا ، لكن بالنسبة إلى هؤلاء الرجال
الذين أصيبوا ليس نهاية القتال ،
إنه انقطاع ، وهل
ستعود إلى
كل شيء هيلز  على جسدي ربما في
غضون ثلاثة إلى أربعة أسابيع يجب
أن أعود هناك